there is so much to do here in New York  it's an incredible town such an amazing  place unfortunately we're only here a  couple of days hard to get everything  done I have a limited amount of time  here in New York City and actually  speaking of which I just faked looked at  my watch you know I'm part would you  excuse me for a second  you better fake get out of yeah you're  not helping  I have to take care of something right  away this is important I'll be right  back you hang on for just a second  everybody  [Applause]  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  [Music]  love om explained through January at the  Metropolitan Opera House but then again  you all knew that TJ Miller coming right  up  you